I'm Dorothy confirm being the returning
officer at the above election do hereby
give notice that the number of votes
recorded for each candidate at the said
election is as follows Henderson in
Christopher UK Independence Party 1361
three one six logon Robert the
Conservative Party candidate 20 1202
[Music]
- one two zero zero so
Louis Ivan lame party 27,000
[Applause]
and Paige Andrew James bills and Liberal
Democrats what 1065 106 5 right Peter
independent to 4 for the number of other
papers rejected was as follows to the
one to the fish'll mark 0 voting for
more candidates than the voter was
entitled to 17 writing or mark by which
the voter could be identified one being
unmarked or wholly void for in certainty
105 and that is a total of 123 the
Turner was sixty nine point three four
percent and I do by declare the newest
Ivan is duly elected
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I would like to begin by paying a
tribute to the returning officer and her
staff the incredibly efficient and
effective way they have conducted this
camp they have been a great credit to
the borough at Barry this evening and we
pay tribute to them I also want to pay
tribute to Greater Manchester Police let
us be honest this has been incredibly
difficult three weeks to be involved in
politics to ask people for their votes
in the aftermath of the horrendous
heinous acts that were committed in
Manchester and then in London Oh Liam
recently but we short on this occasion
take this opportunity to pay tribute the
police the ambulance services and the
fire services does a remarkable job on
our behalf
[Applause]
and I want to say this to you know what
politics is not an easy business but
actually this contest in very South has
been remarkably good-natured and I say
to my opponents thank you for a decent
and fair Democratic contest because I
also say this it may surprise people
okay it may surprise you my politics and
david Norton's politics could not be
further apart but he's actually a pretty
decent human being in the term for the
way he's treated me as colleagues in
Westminster over the last seven years so
David thank you and I have some
individual Atlanteans to me tonight as
well
I decided living in his campaign to
appoint somebody to vote my agent is me
50 years a member of the Labour Party
a guy called Elliot Moss
[Applause]
now Elliott is a detail month and four
weeks ago he asked me the names of all
the people the dates of birdies and the
addresses that the people will be an
account on behalf of the Labour Party
this evening I had to remind him I had
one or two other things on my mind at
that time and also like to pay an
enormous tribute to a young man it was
work with me at Westminster a relatively
short period of time who came to this
constituency
to organize my campaign and I'm so proud
of the job that Chris James did on
behalf of us in ferry south during this
[Music]
and David Jones thank you so much for
all that you do in Barry south and for
all you've got to support me personally
over a very long period of time and
tonight I also need to pay tribute to a
couple of other people hazel Cemal who
runs my office and to be honest
sometimes it feels as though she's
trying to run my life but I need
somebody to run my life and also like to
thank the labor activists in Barry south
what a remarkable group of people you
know what they said four weeks ago we'd
lost we were finished it was all over we
were going to lose this election and
when their backs were against the wall
what did they do they said never we're
going to fight and fight again for labor
values in Barry itself and I'm only
still here because of those people so
thank you so much for all that you have
done
but there's also be honest this election
we've been dependent on support from
lots of friends across the labour family
in Greater Manchester unlike their
particular tribute from the Labour group
on Manchester City Council who came here
night after night and helped us to make
this victory possible and there's a
couple of other people are like to
mention tonight too and really proud of
the fact that my son Ben is here tonight
it's not easy being the son of a
politician and I'm delighted to announce
to everybody here that this week he got
his first ever job so he's going to be
introducing the world at work having
spent his whole life studying I'm really
relieved about that well Ben I'm so
proud of young delighted that you're
here tonight
a couple of other people I'd like to say
that during the last few months I've had
the privilege of working with Beth
Knowles and from tomorrow morning from
tomorrow morning we are going to work
for Andy Berlin on ending rough sleeping
and homelessness across Greater
Manchester there is nothing more
important than that
[Music]
and it's very rare politicians pay
tribute to journalists I'm going to tell
you now I don't apologize for this in
the slightest over the last couple of
years a BBC journalist who covers
politics entirely in policy and
objectively has been fighting the curse
of cancer and he's here tonight
and he's about to meet that curse of
cancer and Jonathan alley we are so
proud of the fight that we made and the
courage he was shown in the fight
against cancer
[Applause]
people need to understand what this
matter why this matters so much to me I
was born raised and have lived all of my
life in very South this is the
constituency which has given me
everything in my life and this is the
sixth time that the people at very south
of electively honored me to be their
representative in Parliament they can be
no greater honor for a local person than
to be the parliamentary representative
for your own community in Westminster
and they are the people that have stuck
with me through thick and thin and
through ups and downs and when people
said he was over what was the message he
sent tonight the game was one of the
best majority who have had other than in
1997 so I thank them to the support that
they have given me but can I also say
this we have a unique opportunity now as
a consequence of the events of tonight
myself and James Street are we proud of
the fact that James Smith is a newly
elected member of parliament of area
[Applause]
but it's not the title you hold it's the
difference you make and James and I are
going to work every single day to get a
fair deal for very little of overdue
[Applause]
friends let me talk briefly about the
national election this is a triumph of
Hope over fear this was an election
where people attempted to terrorize
people to frighten people against voting
labor in this election and what actually
happened was that young people in their
droves came out and said not in our
country because the labour party is
offering us hope and the Tory party are
offering us fear and division and that
is why we have the result that we can in
Basel and across this country
[Applause]
[Music]
and let me say something else unity
unity when this campaign started who
would have believed it later party
completely united in the country
completely United here in bearing and
the Tory party divided from top to
bottom what is the lesson for our party
in our movement when we are united we
win and let us learn that lesson from
what has happened here and elsewhere
this evening
[Applause]
and finally friends this country faces
an incredibly challenging period whoever
the government of this country is has to
negotiate our exit from the European
Union I wanted to stay in the European
Union I thought it was the right thing
to do I thought is in the national
interest but the people have spoken and
we respect that decision but as a
consequence of that decision we are
going to be in almost a post-war era it
serves the future of Britain
okay what kind of country is Britain
going to be in the future is he going to
be a country that works in the interest
of the few or is it going to be a
country that works in the interests of
the many and as these brexit
negotiations develop is absolutely
essential that Parliament scrutinizes
whoever is in government but we also
recognize this that in the end if you
purely have a model which is about
economic trickle-down growth and you do
not care about social justice and
fairness for the many and opportunities
for all the British people will turn the
back on that vision of a future so let
us make this brexit period not a period
of despair and misery but let's turn it
into a period of vision for a brighter
British vision for the kind of country
that we can be ladies and gentlemen it
is a tremendous honor for me to be
elected once again to be the Member of
Parliament for very south but we are
entering one of those critical phases in
our country's history and you know
what's it for
as we come together we act in the
national interest we reach out the cross
party divides and we remember the
statement the young people have made in
this election they want politicians
focused on their heat not on political
fighting and the same old type of
politics thank you very much
[Applause]